with medical and recreational marijuana
legalization spreading across the
country reason attended the cannabis
World Congress and business exposition
in New York City to get a sense of where
things are headed with commercialized
weed and weed related products we
encountered retired pro football players
promoting non psychoactive CBD oils that
they say have replaced the opioids they
once needed to dull their pain if it
wasn't for a company like elixir on the
products that we produce I don't know
where I'd be right now we sampled cold
brewed coffee infused with a marijuana
extract that won't get you stoned but
still makes for a calmer morning it
helps minimize the jitters and cold
recall we learned why candy is the go-to
product for edibles if you're smoking
and you get the munchies and you want
that extra high what are you gonna go
for a quick snack so you have your
edibles you have your weed your elevated
and we talked to an attorney who's going
state-by-state where weed is legal to
fight for laws that clear away the
criminal records of nonviolent drug
offenders if you're going to make
something legal continuing to burden
them with a lifelong criminal record
makes no sense but by far the most
vision inducing part of the conference
was keynote speaker Billy Tauzin
he's a former conservative congressman
from Louisiana who went on to head up
pharma the pharmaceutical industry's
massive lobbying group now he works for
Len ative labs a medical cannabis
company founded by TV host Ms sufferer
and longtime legalization advocate
Montel Williams chosen himself survived
a life-threatening bout with cancer and
now he says he wishes he could have
smoked weed to ease his pain took 65
pounds off of me beat the hell out of me
I'm watching patients today take
advantage of marijuana if you can get
through that a lot easier and I'm
thinking wow why didn't we have that
opportunity when I went through 15 years
ago do all former congressmen have to
get cancer before we're going to get
medical marijuana or recreational
marijuana and I hope most members of
Congress don't have to go through that
I told the group today I think if we
took a silent vote secret ballot we'd
win them more easily if you were a
member of Congress and you've been
taught all your life but this is a bad
entry drug that it's gonna get your
children addicted and they're gonna
become a life of drugs drug addicts or
what have you
you've got some convincing on your hands
right you've got to somehow say no
that's not we tell them oh we're talking
about adult use we're talking about
medical use we're talking about
something very different that's been
kept from you in the public for years by
simply bad policy and so the dark ages
thinking we somehow have to educate him
that it's literally in their interest to
make changes in policy why because their
constituents want them to you were also
the head of Pharma the lobbying group
for the pharmaceutical industry a lot of
people in the legalization space are
worried that big pharma is going to try
and keep marijuana from becoming legal
are those concerns warranted the
pharmaceutical industry is all about
finding new medicines and when it's
legally possible for them to to go to
the FDA with medical marijuana products
they're going to be doing that as I told
the group today they probably going to
want to come around and see you if
you've if you've already pioneered these
medicines and you've got them in the
marketplace they can want to talk to you
about acquiring your companies one day
they're in that business for Christ's
sake no I don't think they're going to
fight it I think they're going to
probably watch wait and see if the
legalization spreads as I think it will
around the country Congress wakes up and
you know passes the laws that take it
off the schedules and let them become
investigators and researchers into the
exact why and how it works I think
they're going to be partners with this
this group today he's just got it
literally takes some time for it to
happen
Tosun has never been a full-on
libertarian but his experiences have
taught him a valuable lesson about self
ownership and he supports the right to
try bill recently signed by Donald Trump
giving terminally ill patients access to
experimental medications libertarians
have it right there we ought to have a
right to our own body and our own
protection if I want to try something do
under the right to try it I hate the
notion as I told
today that the medicine that saved my
life is off-label and the company can't
tell other people that it could be
useful in pancreatic medicine they can
only use it for the label that is
labeled for at least well to open that
up we ought to let people talk about the
real life experiences with medicines and
which ones help which people one thing
I've learned is how different we are
biologically and the medicine that's
going to work for you may not work for
me we ought to be able to tell those
stories whatever let's share them on the
Internet learn from yeah there's gonna
be some mistakes made but I'd love to
live in that world rather than one that
denies us access is something they could
save our lives
Donald Trump has said at the urging of
Cory Gardner a Republican senator from
Colorado that he would sign a bill
returning marijuana laws and regulation
to the states are you confident that he
will do that if presented with that and
and you know well Congress actually
write something and vote on something
two good questions
as to the first I think one day Congress
will if we if we if we little they
advocate properly I think they want to
do that this question of giving in the
courage to do it
that's the Trump keeping his word you
may not like him one bit but he keeps
his word and whatever he told you in
that campaign you following through on
it to a lot of people's consternation
he's doing exactly what he said he when
he says he'd sign that bill wait a final
question what's the timeline for full
legalization of marijuana is it ten
years is it fifteen years is it already
happening you know when what will go
outside of this Convention Center and
it'll be done a done deal I've learned
something about the progress of mankind
anytime you try to predict it's going to
take longer than you think you're
probably wrong this is moving fast this
tide has turned it would pass the
tipping point they know no coming back I
think this is going to happen within
five
have you ever misled funny people man
have you ever